Philippines president Rodrigo Duterte
has now personally admitted to killing
criminal suspects when he was the mayor
of Davao the background of this is that
there's already nearly six thousand
people said to have been killed by
police and vigilantes and mercenaries
since duterte launched his drug war he
was elected in May and he said we need
to be out there killing suspected note
the word suspected drug dealers we need
to be out there killing suspected drug
addict and suspected criminals and he
was mentioned in terms of his connection
to Donald Trump last week in her I can
Wald's Newsweek piece about Donald
Trump's conflicts and that piece alleges
that Donald Trump recently spoke to
duterte and told him that he supports
his fight against drug dealers and
reportedly invited him to the White
House
we now have learned that he quote in
Davao I used to do it personally just to
show the guys referring to the police
that if I can do it
why can't you and I'd go around and
devour with a motorcycle with a big bike
around and I would just patrol the
streets looking for trouble I was really
looking for a confrontation so I could
kill and he has indeed admitted to
killing at least three men suspected of
kidnapping and rape in the Filipino city
of Davao killing suspects not criminals
condemned to die by any justice system
but suspects he has expressed basically
no regrets about the policy and he
actually referenced Hitler you can't
write this stuff but it's all too real
he once said hey listen Hitler massacred
3 million Jews there's 3 million drug
addicts I'd be happy to slaughter them
all so where did he come up with the
number 3 million of course the number is
6 million Jews killed in the Holocaust
but it's still insane to compare
yourself favorably to Adolf Hitler and
the fact that Trump reportedly had no
problem praising him or inviting him to
the White House not confirmed nor denied
by the Trump transition team that speaks
volumes but it's also not that
surprising because Donald Trump has
praised a Turkish president
Oh on four quote turning the cou around
and he's also praised Vladimir Putin in
some ways there's also this debating
tactic called argumentum at Hitler room
which yes you compare your opponents
position to one of Hitler or the Nazi
Party yeah it's crazy that he's
bolstering his own opinion by tearing
himself to Hitler in this case it's less
common to compare yourself to Hitler in
rhetorical debate basically Trump just
loves authoritarian strongmen
dictatorial types he himself is one of
those types of we as we've seen from his
tendencies and if there's one thing you
know we talk about Trump a lot and about
how he flip-flops and he's not
consistent
there is one thing Donald Trump has
really been consistent on and it's that
he has expressed admiration and/or
support for different vicious people
around the world we have here a
president that wants to kill and admits
the killing in the Philippines supported
by Donald Trump this is America 2016
today's show is brought to you by go
daddy where you can buy your own domain
name build a website or use any of Go
Daddy's business tools you can save 30
percent at Tri godaddy.com slash David
GoDaddy has actually been the official
host of the David Pakman show website
for many many many years the 24/7
customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we've had website issues
and they are always available they are
the largest domain registrar and whether
you have a new idea you're an
established business you're creating a
personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all 13 million customers try it
and get 30% off at try go daddy.com
slash David